خليني اقول لك انه ثاني اكسيد الكربون
يحاصر العالم هذه الحقيقه المؤكده
والمؤسفه وصل اليها العلماء خلال رصدهم
لارقامهم الاخيره بلغت نسب انتشار ثاني
اكسيد الكربون في الهواء الان اعلى مستوى
لها منذ اكثر من اربعه ملايين لماذا بسبب
حرق النفط والفحم والغاز الاداره الوطنيه
للمحيطات والغلاف الجوي في الولايات
المتحده
اعلنت ان مستوى الغاز السام وصل الى
جزء في المليون الرقم المسجل يزيد بمقدار
ثلاثه اجزاء في المليون مقارنه بمتوسط
مايو للعام الماضي مسجلا علوا بالنسبه 51%
مقارنه بمستويات ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه
والتي بلغت 280 جزءا في المليون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات